I thought this was a good question by
peers what is the difference between you
and Trump in terms of style
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
you're Diet Coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff
what are the differences between you
well I know what I I know him very well
I'm having now spent time with you I
could imagine identify a few differences
but what do you think of the differences
well I mean I think there's a few things
I mean obviously you know the approach
to covid was different I mean you know I
would have fired somebody like fauci I
think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important yeah it's a solid answer
it gets to my point about competency
about the type of people that you have
around you and if you were to get to the
White House again regardless who the
candidate is do you have the staff that
will keep their eye on the ball that
will complete the mission that won't be
leaking left and right is it all going
to be about drama and firing people and
press secretaries that are there for
three days like Anthony scaramucci or
whatever else I think that is a really
Stark difference that that DeSantis can
say hey here's what I've done and now my
roughly five years in Florida here's the
staff that I've brought along with me
that has been airtight and professional
and deals with the media properly and we
don't have leaks as he said last week
we've never had a leak now by the way
it'll be completely different if they
make it to DC because there is that
never-ending swamp state that exists
there it's much harder to keep things
under wraps it's a whole other challenge
so that I grant him that but I think
that's a that's a really strong point
that if they get to that debate stage uh
it's like hey Donald who can you staff
your team with at this point who wants
to work for you who haven't you turned
against Etc et cetera there's something
there
[Music]